[Music]
foreign
cruelty
you've been fighting the arguments for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries
they were massacred
alongside my father
your father didn't believe in Revenge
[Music]
let me fight beside you
reload
[Music]
he said I got that
thanks
I won't be fighting for him
I'm fighting for my people
[Music]
you young pop
e do you believe in Paul
there are science
the prophet why is that a bad thing use
it because all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paul the tradies are still alive
deal with this prophet
[Music]
show me who you are
your father
was a weak man
look who's back from the dead
no do it must be done
we gave them something to hope for
I will love you as long as I breathe
this prophecy is how they enslave us
it's not a prophecy it's a story I don't
care what you believe I believe
I am poor boy Diva tradies
joke Uncle rackets
to the blessings
who can destroy a thing as the real
control of it
[Music]
it's breathtaking
when you see sand here imagine water if
you dive in you can't reach the bottom
you dive in yes it's called swimming I
don't I don't believe you
in the shadows of arrakis lie many
secrets
but the darkest of them all may remain
my father didn't believe
it
all the treaties were still alive
have you ever had a dream about your
first ride
you're brave we all know that
be simple be direct
nothing fancy I understand
nothing fancy
[Music]
we gave them something to hope for
May thy knife chip and shatter
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign